you have posted videos and written about
what is happening in Gaza since October
7th what has been happening there the
individual stories and the broader
impact on the 2 million people there
razza has been described as the world's
largest open air prison unemployment
blockaded from all directions no
airport um Regular added restrictions
placed even on their ability to fish
so every aspect of razin life has been
under occupation I would argue that it's
an injustice to even call it an open air
prison
because inmates are not bombed in
prisons routinely by the most
sophisticated weapons in the world
regular bombardment of Gazza every
single person in Gaza has lived through
multiple rounds of
bombardment it is deep deeply uh
distressing you know I I remember in uh
2021 there was an
image that I will never forget of
children having to go back to school
after the bombardment of
and next to them they would have the
empty chairs and the posters of the
child that used to sit in that
chair I think what encapsulates it most
for
me an image that I grew up with was the
image of Muhammad who was in his
father's lap over 20 years ago and his
father was begging for Israel to spare
his child and Muhammad was murdered in
his
lap and you know what happened this last
round his other kids were murdered so
Muhammad's brothers were murdered and
his father's been on the run every
single person in Gaza has witnessed
multiple Wars has witnessed the the
greatest Suffocation of
occupation has even had their diets
restricted and has suffered under Israel
State policy which is called mowing the
lawn and everyone should look this up
this is what Israeli ministers refer to
as routine bombardment of Gazza mowing
the
lawn which shows you that before they
called us animals they considered us
insects and unfortunately the casualty
counts get higher and higher every time
and people become more and more
desperate more and more helpless
Gaza has been unfortunately the worst
manifestation of anti- Palestinian
bigotry it's already I mean 60% of the
population is a refugee population what
that means and people do need to
understand this is that people move to
Gazza from other parts of occupied
territory to find
refuge and we're practically living on
top of each
other there are people that are in the
gazda strip that know that they had
homes right beyond that apartheid wall
and those homes were stolen from them
and they can't even enter that territory
anymore and they know that on the other
side of that wall there's life on the
other side of that wall there's
opportunity on the other side of that
wall you have a passport you have an
airport you have the ability to travel
you have the ability to export and
import you can dream but behind that
wall you are to live until the next air
strike you are to live until Israel mows
the lawn again and hope that you're not
part of the grass that's what Gaza has
been all of these years so pragmatically
and psychologically it is very difficult
to
flourish when you're just waiting for
more bombardments cuz you know that it's
around the corner you always know when
you live in Gaza that it's only a matter
of time before the next bombs drop you
know if you're in
Gazza
that you you are waiting for your
death people dream about going out in
the world and pursuing education people
dream about going out in the world and
pursuing Economic Opportunity in
Gazza your idea of opportunity is an
opportunity to see the next year that
has been the case and so when we talk
about you know this not existing in a
vacuum if people only hear about
Gazza on October 7th that is that is a
major part of the problem and that is
Again part of the problem of our
ignorance and our apathy right why is it
that the plight of the people of Gazza
is not brought
up until an attack happens on
Israel I've gotten a chance to witness a
destroyed School in
Ukraine it's something
that is really difficult to see you have
over 100 destroyed mosques every
University in Gaza has been demolished
we're seeing Tik Tock videos of Israeli
soldiers laughing and
singing as they press a button and we
see the demolition of every single
University in Gaza schools have been
reduced to Rubble there's a cultural
genocide as well I want you to think
about what you saw in Ukraine look
imagine coming back to school in Gaza
and some destroyed building you're
missing legs you're missing arms you
have white phosphorus Burns have you
ever seen what white phosphorus does to
a person there's a reason why it's a war
crime you have white phosphorus burns
your mom's dead your dad's dead all of
your uncles and aunts are dead all of
your siblings are dead somehow you got
pulled out of the
Rebel you know in my own family my
father's in-laws my father remarried
after my mother passed away um and
they're in
Gaza all of of them were killed in an
air strike except for an elderly Aunt
who somehow made it out of the Rebel a
day later if you're a child that's been
pulled out of the rubel what are you
going to grow up with I mean what are
you supposed to feel what are you
supposed to
think and then you have you
know racist commentators that say they
could have turned that into a Singapore
you know the Palestinians are the
authors of their own destruction
because if they wanted to they could
have turned this into a place of
prosperity but they keep on bringing
destruction upon themselves so at the
root of this is a bigotry and again this
idea that uh Palestinians are savages
they're animals and the only way to deal
with them is to continuously mow the
lawn while simultaneously expanding the
occupation and erasing anything that was
ever called Palestine and any human
being that was ever called the
Palestinian
so those kids growing up in Gaza now to
you they have almost no choice but to
have
hatred for
Israel it's
human I mean look any
child that is under that type of
Oppression is going to hate their
oppressor I don't care who you are I
don't care what you are but here's my
problem with how that gets brought
up you're talking about the future of
the security of Israel even some people
that speak about it uh seemingly from a
place of being well-meaning that say the
only way that Israel can have its
Security is to stop killing Palestinians
and so the future of Israel depends upon
Palestinians not hating Israel so much
and so we've got to stop tormenting
these people so that they don't grow up
to want to torment us you've already
decided then whose life is worth more
than the other and so instead of talking
about the future
of Israeli Lives why don't you talk
about the present of Palestinian lives
instead of talking about whether or not
your state will be secure in the
future talk to me about why you're
killing children now 2third of the
30,000 civilians are women and children
and so uh we can't talk about what these
children are going to grow up with we
should talk about whether or not these
children are going to grow up in the
first place and that should be what
dominates our conscience right now and
what drives our policies and what drives
our emotions right
now